happy Wednesday hump day
hump day my day I agree this is your day
he created it we're here today Pacific
Rim uprising another trailer starring J
Boyana yeah nailed it 200%
I like his Back to the Future 2 haircut
yeah it looks great guys
we're gonna watch this but we have to
give a shout-out today because we are
killing it on the start yeah and we want
you to follow us this is Uncle Sam
telling you to follow the real rejects
on the start us at people 30-second
reactions or reviews for a film TV show
or trailer to Rooney Magnus is on a
Jimmy John's is honest Munoz this is on
it leads on it and late to the party
Zanna coxinhas on it there's a whole lot
of people on it look your Piketty is on
it anyway hey guys yeah make sure to
down the link and follow us first and
page from the day shout-out gonna go out
to Andrew Hayes Andy okay
[Music]
he saves cheek your father always said
he wanted you to be a pilot he said a
party animal whoa
transfers he better gear up Wow
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
there are pilots we remember as legends
but they didn't start that way
they started unlike us
time to make a difference
Wow do you want me to find out
movie line
[Music]
and be a long day
[Music]
defects like great great I like this new
trend of ending trailers on a shot where
you're like what what what is happening
there I don't quite get that well dude I
got a say man yeah I'm running into a
lot of circles of people who seem to be
like thrashing on this movie really yeah
I mean people who are like oh like the
idea of John boyega being in this movie
why not I don't know he's saying that
this is LA circles I'm running in there
by the way this is not like internet
comments I'm going off of here and I
talk of Internet comments it's just to
know the Transformers film all over
again I would like that well I think
that there's imagery that seems very
similar to transformers I've been saying
since like couple trailers ago that this
one looks like it's gonna be a lot more
fun like I feel like they're gonna hone
in on the fun side with a lot of the
dialogue that you see in this trailer a
lot of the moments the way this is all
being executed
I get the strong impression that this
one is gonna just know a lot more of
what this really is and just have a
total blast doing it this looks cheesy
it looks really fun it looks incredibly
entertained the effects look cool just
looks like a Rock'em Sock'em good time
cuz honestly one thing that I felt was
the first Pacific Rim was I wasn't
really enjoying it unless they're
worried Yeager's and Kai's you fighting
each other it is a little rot sometimes
yeah it kind of drags in the scenes
where there's not Kai's you and Yeager's
fighting each other and there are
certain elements in those scenes that
are wooden so that like the action
shines that much brighter than some of
the stories I'm not saying like the
scenes here are gonna be incredible but
it looks like at least the dialogue
scenes might be more fun it looks like
there will probably be like a more a
beat vibe about it something works like
we just want people to go to theaters
and have a Rock'em Sock'em good time
throughout this entire experience
I feel like this movie is gonna get me
pumped I'm just gonna have a great time
watching it
I'm going to be able to turn off my
brain and have a good time it's probably
because I feel like having guillermo del
toro behind the first one you're
expecting sort of a cooler story and
cooler character says el Toro is known
to provide that in fantasy films and you
don't really get them the first Pacific
Rim so I feel like with its the director
Stephen tonight and this one I think he
knows he's just gonna make a really
solid entertaining film and I highly
doubt that I will be bored at all
watching this film and also the action
looks incredible yeah it does it does it
does
I guess my hope for this movie is that
they split the difference between that
like I don't want this to be just a
hundred percent only brainless fun
however I do think that coming out of
the first Pacific Rim there's stuff you
could improve on their stuff you can
make snappy or there's stuff that you
could make yeah yeah more fun part of
what I liked so much about the first one
as compared to a transformers or
something like that is that it did have
its heart and its mind in a place other
than just we got our destroy stuff like
there is sort of a culmination of the
world coming together to face a threat
there's a humanity vibe underneath it
yeah and so I hope this movie carries
that DNA over a while like it looks like
it is they hone in on a plot point of
someone on our earth let in the kaiju
and yeah I'm very feeling that why oh
come on if you're gonna have it be
different from other stuff like I don't
know and then it could is not different
from others though but it arguably
should be distinct because the whole
argument is like you then you can say
it's Gundam it's any Godzilla movie it's
transformed it's it is it's a no Marvel
yeah but it's specifically linking to
those types of films and I don't know it
to me that Mike I don't really care
about that kind of thing I just care for
a Rock'em Sock'em good time I don't
think anyone walked away from the first
one being like the mythology in the
world building behind it well that added
a dimension that made it more than a
forgettable good time like a memorable
Rock'em Sock'em good
has some other things on its mind other
than just cool punch you know and I've
seen cool punch a lot of time I think
your expectations need to be lowered I
don't this movie to be an Oscar thing
the original Pacific Rim leaves room for
improvement and I don't want them to go
down instead of up is my point I don't
want them to devolve because the thing
about mindless fun is you can go too far
and you can make something forgettable
and something that will pale in
comparison to a Transformers which I
really don't want for Pacific Rim like I
said I want them to split the difference
I want them to keep the stuff that they
started the first time but bring in more
fun so that it isn't quite as as kind of
a long movie after a while the first
Pacific Rim you know I'm not against fun
and I think what they're doing with john
boyega's care for this Jake guy being
that dude who lost his dad and he's a
party animal at first and he has to find
his calling it's all very cliche and
generic but like I said I think that's
what adds an element of fun to the
characters now is having that side to
seeing him like laying on the falling
asleep on the pool with a hot girl on
his back and then there's like the
skeleton of one of the kaiju they're
like stuff like that makes it seem like
just the scenes might be fun in general
and the attention to details and stuff
yeah yeah I think ultimately we probably
want the same thing and we're just
expressing it too differently I have a
feeling I'm gonna walk out disappointed
hey you're gonna walk out really like
just like the stacker Pentecost named
his son anyway hey guys Paige from the
day shout out today for Andrew Hayes
Andrew my buddy I was talking with you
and pastry on recently you want to come
out to California this dude has a movie
review channel that you guys got to
check out right away Andrew if you come
out to California you are crashing on my
bed sleeping next to me waking me up
with a good blowy in the morning okay
buddy
because that is one of your reward tiers
on patreon yeah you get six
so I hope that you are able to honor
this reward tier and come out here and
sleep next to Greg so I can wake up more
relaxed in the morning I have sleep
apnea and this would really help out
buddy also I'm gonna try to go out to
the East Coast again closer to like fall
winter time this year Halloween girls
yeah I'm gonna go trick-or-treating all
around that hat so I hope that if I go
out there that I can meet up with you
too because we need to do a
collaboration together buddy
yeah it would be linked in the
description box for Andrew Hayes's
channel guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up with all the new
YouTube changes none of those will
probably work but do it anyway it makes
for a flashy subscriber count' number
for the day uh also make sure to
download and follow us on the stardust
app that does not go down and followers
when you subscribe to us there